are you one that watches the movies
you're in maybe after do you watch them
later on years later you do when's the
last time you saw
aliens oh I
haven't I've seen parts of aliens
probably in the last six months but I've
seen aliens aliens the best movie I've
ever been in without a doubt aliens is
the best movie did you think it would be
well we had High Hopes cuz Jim had done
the Terminator and the sets were
incredible and you know a good script
when you one so yes did we have high
hopes we had like yeah very very high
hopes but you never know there's a great
book called The Devil's candy about
making bonfire the vanities and how they
thought they had something so special
back then and uh Bruce Willis and they
fired Morgan Freeman off of it that's
how great they thought this thing was
and they thought it was great you know
and but everybody's invested in it you
know the actors are invested the
directors invested the crews invested
the producers are invested the studio is
invested so everybody's you know
invested in it and they all thought they
had the best movie you know going
Academy Awards right down the line and
it came out people hated it it's
terrible and it's a great book called
Dirty candy so you never really know of
a if a movie is going to be uh well
regarded successful until you put it in
front of an audience